previously on the walking dead well this
is as far as we're going
oh it's him but no sure she's been
bitten Oh take it easy
ah [ __ ] I'm gonna help you can't wear as
next order of business has given those
pills out of the pharmacy
trapped over there huh no it's him I
have to go over I'm in a really weird
moon right now I just totally not
fitting this setting hey what are you
looking at his eyes are just what are
you doing bro
all right we need to talk to everyone
apparently and I don't think I've been
doing that yes I have actually
we need a plan I don't want to talk to
Clementine what's up Clemmy it's
everything all right there girl
your booth ruku mm-hmm hi girl stay
awesome let's do what you're doing I
feel so bad for her I don't know why
it's not looking for batteries forever
okay I appreciate it maybe we should
check in this room over here I mean this
is no that's a rest room
we should talk to him actually when they
ever talk to him gladden is there not
rain to equip you know all right
back at the Motor Inn all right what's
your next move
looks Moo I don't know I mean you guys
seem okay what about your fehb yeah I I
forget a bit tell me gland rule business
I mean don't worry about anything like I
can't do anything I know the feeling
I don't know why they're [ __ ] talking
about I get the combination for the lock
on the gate outside why oh no I thought
I'd go stretch my legs
why can't he just be honest I'll
breaking it if you have to all right
we'll just cut it off with ax then why
is it lagging come on Glenn all right
back of the motor and how can it be that
bad so fast you know when things are
taken away people do crazy [ __ ] I guess
that's not me yet not coming up not for
anything that's a spade Glenn good
[ __ ] love you guys yes she really
wanted that gun brofist Weinberg
why didn't you tell Carly to just give
it to her
it was a waste of a bullet waste of a
bullet what do you mean she was dead
anyway
I'm not in the euthanasia business whoa
man
Oh person she's going now anyway I
didn't mean to be so heartless Yeah
right
I didn't mean to be sound like an
[ __ ] I just met Sarah to say she was
getting and I feel look at me like that
I I think it's gonna be a [ __ ] about it
okay we have no pills I have nothing but
we should check in here actually I get
the feeling there's batteries in here I
know why Clementine follows me though
Clemmy Clemmy
this has gotta be offer State hello
this music is beautiful it's got to be
something else a clear path to open in
that door
what what is it
do you see something Clemmy what's up
Clemmy
talk to me what is that that I don't
know climbing I ask the same thing yes
my dad's gay ah your honor from time to
time sick uh he was okay I actually saw
him whoops top lifters with it paints
protected this place better than any
guard dog ever could I all possibly like
you my dad gave it to me
ah too smart like that sure I sure I'd
clay me like you claiming not gonna like
this door for when we found the keys
alright let's clear this historically
huh I just feel like yeah sure we're it
seemed funny here we go watch your
fingers in the drawers alright so how
you doing clammy
how are you doing yeah it's not that
heavy
nine men with everything outside I meant
with that not good
tell me what's out of it but I think
it'll be okay
that's a spared Clemmy okay that's why I
love you that face is gorgeous alright
you video kids no no you don't have a
family
don't worry claiming I have you what do
your parents do what are your parents -
my mom is a doctor and my dad is an
engineer like me what's your job
teach history right things like that
yeah all right like um social studies
yeah like that yeah like that yourselves
mark lemme like I didn't answer my
question
goddamnit Clemmy don't be so smart I
just feel like someone bad kid it is for
a reason why don't you want to talk
about your family do they like hate you
Clemmy
I hope not it's this Cobb okay it's just
complicated that's all why it just is
this Clemmy but you love them right of
course course it's it's complicated
planning others gone and I just wish
things were different
you see yeah I'm not a bad guy I'm not a
bad guy okay things happen and we didn't
talk much after that my parents don't
talk to me when I get in trouble
ah complete I can't relate to that - hey
I'm in here - you know it don't it for
four people here hey okay Chloe huh grab
a yogurt it's not good a little okay
climb eight calm down we're gonna fix
this I'll find you a bed there's the
first date over here I saw it in case of
this would happen
there's a bandaid in there calm down
clammy oh good I got you back let me
I know what it's called in English
Gloucester hey you gonna fly me take the
plus there he also gained reverb finger
oh it hurt let's see if we can do
something about it honestly I wouldn't
touched her
all right let's get this cut camera go
yes please stop big hug count
I don't worry clammy there you got like
nyet
how the hell did you come here
yeah what's up your room what if my
parents I'm home and I'm not there their
finest tracker spell that way yeah okay
we should keep a lookout we should write
my walkie-talkie in case they tried that
way
that's my climbing hooks to me until
then okay alright I'll keep you safe
climbing don't even worry about it let's
use the axe to get past this story cuz
he trying the doorknob it's just silly
it's not working huh the keys are on
that zombie oh oh well we need a plan to
get those maybe these remotes has like a
battery perhaps to be in them
or maybe we can look at the TV or don't
figure it's not working huh well we have
the batteries so let's I think we're
done in here
climate let's roll let's kill Holmes I'm
his girl aren't you gonna lift her down
okay again well let's chick without
radio I think the batteries might be a
little small I don't I don't know I hate
that tiny little battle Carly are you
seriously just kind of chill here I'm
still looking for batteries but we found
the remote
come on you're serious what is this
the IT guy that's supposed to mean
energy bar let's see a looks like nobody
got a chance to donate anything before
this all went down that's a shame
it's first time I'm actually stuck in
this game
I mean we can't just rush out without a
plan
can we does it make sense can we or can
we not well we do you don't mind I think
my family and I are gonna rest for a bit
I know of that [ __ ] over there takes
a turn for the worse
come on don't be like that there's a
menu so mildewed new
it's not another thanks battery all
right Cole I found it
she says he couldn't find that herself
are you kidding me
I thought it would be something more
about it let's check out these greeting
come on Carly I thought better of you
man yeah here your loved one was eaten
by the Living Dead cards oh you can make
a joke signle you think this is time for
jokes man
people are dying Lee you're so heartless
all right here you go you lazy son of a
sorry
but seriously what the fogger shoots
with the radio how about thanks next
time you just don't [ __ ] sit there and
stare at the thing I'm still looking for
batteries I did more come on dude
ah you're the old thing
greeting cards photographs yep we're
gonna talk to you how we doing good want
to go have a look around outside yeah
let's have a look around okay this is
gonna be stupid all right it's a
combination lock I know that are you
gonna use the remotes it's universal not
that universe
I know I know doc all right I'll do it
I don't think this is the great idea
Michael I awesome why is that awesome
distract those things i thoughtfully how
oh now I can just write I thought I'd uh
uh oh I used a remote on the TV store
that is really crazy that works think
you can do anything with this
I could do put it up your [ __ ] it's
universal
I could program it to work with those
TVs across the street huh just hope the
powers still on you can program that
just by clicking the same buttons over
and over again prom raised all the codes
and there was a Navy
let's try do it Harry I think carries a
name what and zombies out like aa dog
well [ __ ] done since we'd save a life
all right already hasn't well [ __ ]
dumb dog
how am I on your tabs why what is that
ah let me take notice I don't think
that's enough huh
well what else did we do hasty
fortification job over there didn't work
I think we need that radio actually no
no don't go out don't go out what are
you doing you're gonna die
I'll take it technique technique alright
cuz it's closer closes close close are
you crazy
didn't work uh don't come here please
oh they don't care do they yeah that's a
hasty fortification job over there yeah
didn't work
all right Oh
throw it Lee so I like the man you are
hell yeah for our broth for the old
looking over there now ah ah right hey I
love teddy knows the time
yeah those zombies really like to watch
TV
alright let's go be careful
oh well
[Music]
all right here we go
what's up man hey don't give me that
look
don't give me that look man I know if
you were there
oh it's his brother hey don't y'all give
me a second oh I'm sorry I wasn't there
buddy
[Music]
no he's not gonna I guess you have to ah
[Applause]
do it man whoa
hell [ __ ] it he do I thought it was dead
like John again
finish him I need just go for that in
the beginning or to save us both a lot
of time let's get the keys man and get
out of here there we go there we go
buddy
this is [ __ ] hey bud Oh
oh hey gosh oh [ __ ] alright oh [ __ ] man
alright there we go
you could have closed the gate a little
better you know man do you did what you
had laid so I'm proud of you man [ __ ]
proud of ya respect I don't have your
keys
I have the keys I mean god you're
amazing I know I'm let's make love in
your but let's get in your bed what
all right breasts that was a very
emotional episode I like and favorite if
you enjoy it and I'll see you next
episode of wherever I may stay awesome
bros i know you will
[Music]
no point but sure point but
can I slap you what I read it [ __ ]
second yeah I know what the [ __ ]